hello my name is dr brady carter and i'm
a senior application scientist with new
tech group
and i want to thank you for your
interest in my poster titled the role of
water activity in cannabis quality and
safety
the purpose of this poster was to
provide additional information about
why water activity is important
is an important measurement in the
cannabis industry
and you'll notice that water activity is
now starting to show up on most
state regulations as a required test
and the reason is is because water
activity is related to
many different stability factors in
cannabis
as well as in all types of other
products and water activity has been
used for many
years in the food industry effectively
as a
critical control point it also has that
level of importance in cannabis
so water activity is the energy of water
in a product it is not the free water
it's not the available water
although those terms are used often it
is actually the
energy of the water as derived from
fundamentals of thermodynamics
and so it's important to understand that
distinction because the reason why water
activity does what it does is because
it is showing the energy and one of the
main things that water tv is known for
is its ability to be able to control
microbial growth
and that's one of the main roles it
plays within cannabis
because if you get below a water
activity of 0.7
you've essentially shut down the growth
of all types of
microorganisms there are some molds that
will grow below that but they're not
very common spoilage
molds so if you can get it down below
0.7
then you can and store it that way the
dried cannabis flower won't be
susceptible to mold growth and of course
mold
growth in particularly in cannabis can
be
can be quite dangerous both from
mycotoxin production standpoint but also
because mold spores present
and are inhaled can lead to asthma
but water activity isn't just related to
microbial spoilage as you'll see in
table 1
it's also related to many other
stability factors including chemical
stability
physical stability it affects texture
it affects performance and in particular
in cannabis
as the water activity gets too low the
trichomes on the cannabis as shown in
figure two
start to stiffen and to dry out and they
allow
the evaporation or the evaporating off
of the terpenes and the cannabinoids
and so it it actually is detrimental to
over dry cannabis flowers to to drive a
water activity
and so the ideal water activity range
for cannabis as identified in the astm
standard is
to have a water activity between 0.55
and 0.65
and the reason why this is considered to
be ideal is because
in that range you stop mold growth but
you minimize
the amount of trichome destruction um
and you minimize then the evaporation or
loss of
terpenes and cannabinoids and there
really is no advantage in over drying
there's actually disadvantages
uh to being to being uh or to doing that
and it's important to understand that
that's not driven by moisture content
it's driven by water activity so figure
one shows uh
the moisture absorption isotherm for
cannabis
and there's two curves on here there's
an adsorption curve and a desorption
curve and they are not the same because
of hysteresis
and if we target a 0.62 water activity
the moisture content will be different
if we dry to that point than if you wet
to that point so there's no advantage in
over drying
and trying to wet back up to that water
activity because your moisture content
will actually be less
and you want to maximize that amount of
moisture for
many different reasons and so
moisture content isn't what should be
triggering that decision
it should be based your dry down all
should be controlled through water
activity
trying to target that critical range of
0.55 to 0.65
and in so doing you maximize your
profitability by maximizing your weight
from water you're not over drying you're
not using more energy
so all that comes down to water activity
really playing a critical role
in terms of cannabis quality and safety
and it really needs to be a test that's
run
not only just by testing labs to meet
regulations but it should be utilized by
cultivators and processors to make sure
that they're
getting the they're drying that cannabis
flower to the correct
uh water activity so that it will store
and have its maximum shelf
life as well as not posing any kind of
threat to anyone who consumes it
thank you very much for your attention
uh if you have any questions please feel
free to
reach out and contact me uh at
b carter at newtekgroup.com
or visit our website at www
thank you